this is an exhibit celebrating the 400th
anniversary of the first folio which is
the first edition of the collected plays
of Shakespeare published in 1623. one
reason why we care about this book and
celebrate its anniversary is that it
preserves about half of Shakespeare's
plays that otherwise might have been
lost because they don't appear in other
print editions from the period so plays
like Macbeth and the Tempest that we
think of as being absolutely essential
to the Shakespeare Canon but I think
another reason why we celebrate this
book is a bit more complicated and
connected to Shakespeare's cultural
status because the book itself is not
actually that rare for an early modern
book there's over 200 copies of it so
its value seems less connected to its
Rarity or scarcity and more connected to
the values and meanings that we have
brought to it over the centuries I would
be very happy if people came to the
exhibit who didn't know what the first
folio was to me the really fascinating
story is how it became so important and
in the exhibit I was interested in
exploring that intersection of turning
Shakespeare into a commodity that could
be worth quite a lot foreign
[Music]